PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well today I'm
invited by xMatters
in their kitchen,
and Travis DePuy
is going to walk me
through how they've been through
this journey of migrating
from monolithic application into
microservices on Google Cloud
Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you, Travis,
for having me over.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Thanks for coming.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
Well, I'm super excited to
actually cook with you today
and to eat, because
that's what I like to do.
But before we do
that, I would love
to learn more about xMatters
and what the tool does.
TRAVIS DEPUY: We help
keep digital services up
and running.
We do that by tracking down
the current on call resources,
delivering
notifications to them,
and letting them
initiate workflow.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So what
the tool basically does is,
it takes the times when there's
spikes in traffic or spikes
in error rates, and then it
notifies the right teams.
But that stuff is
really hard to do.
How do you understand
all of that--
and also very complicated?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
Yeah, it is hard, and
important critical work
for the industries today.
And there's, once you get
the notifications, you know,
that's just the
beginning of the process.
There's a lot steps that
have to happen after that.
And so that's called toil.
You know, important manual
work that needs to be done,
but it takes away time from
troubleshooting the issue,
so we can help automate
a lot of that process.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: This sounds,
obviously, very exciting.
I'm interested in
seeing the tool.
Can you show me how this works?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah, sure.
I have a computer right here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Here we see part
of the xMatters flow designer
canvas showing a
Stackdriver alarm workflow.
The first step is the
inbound HDB trigger
that parses the payload
and kicks things off.
Then we start enriching the
alarm with some metadata
that Stackdriver might not have.
In this case, we're getting the
last commit and deployment info
from GitHub and Jenkins.
And finally, this
is where we actually
fire the xMatters
event to notify people.
Here we see Dan receiving
the Stackdriver notification
on his mobile device.
He reviews the stock
info from Stackdriver,
but then he can
review the enriched
from GitHub and Jenkins.
He has a couple of
different response options,
but he decided this
is severe enough
that he needs to roll back
to the blue deployment
from the current
green deployment.
So he selects a response option
and adds an optional comment.
Back in the xMatters campus,
we see the various flows
that kick off when a user
selects the relevant response
option.
Each organization has major
incidents and processes
around kicking those off.
In this case, we
see that xMatters
will automate creating a juror
issue, and then a status page
incident, and finally, a
Slack channel so that teams
can start collaborating.
We also see a rollback to
blue that Dan selected,
and we see that
a new juror issue
is created before triggering
the redeploy using a Kubernetes
command.
The juror issue helps keep track
of who triggered the deployment
and when, and also
serves as a record
for future investigation.
The last one is my
favorite, though.
Using a playbook
tool such as Ansible,
we can go trigger
an existing playbook
to attempt to
remediate the problem.
There are limitless
possibilities,
and all this can be tailored
in the specific processes
of the organization.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I can imagine
how this application must
have looked originally.
So I am super excited to
learn how you guys managed
to take all these services and
separate them out and create
microservices out of them.
But before we do that, I want to
know what we're cooking today.
TRAVIS DEPUY: We're
cooking vegetable soup,
and I think it's going
to be pretty tasty.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK,
Travis, so where do we start?
I am super excited looking
at all these veggies.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
We're going to chop them all up.
So we've got some
celery, some parsley.
We've got some carrots
and some cheese.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Corns
and colorful tomatoes?
Oh, good start.
OK.
So Travis, what do you
think about the difference
between monoliths
and microservices?
How do you define it?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well, if you think
of a monolith like a turducken,
you know, that meat
monstrosity that's
the chicken inside of the
duck inside of the turkey?
A lot like a turducken,
monoliths are very intertwined.
Everything's all put together,
and rolling out new turduckens
is very hard.
You have to rebuild each one.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Just like when
you're trying to build
something and you
have all the things
connected to each other,
and they're dependent
on each other,
and you don't know
which one to take apart,
because the other
things might mess up.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Got it.
OK.
TRAVIS DEPUY:
Conversely, microservices
are a lot like cupcakes, right?
If you have multiple
flavors of cupcakes
and you want to change one
little thing in the recipe,
you can then change the recipe,
bake a bunch of new cupcakes,
and your customers get to have
all the greatest and latest
cupcakes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, that was
the most delicious
explanation of the difference
between monoliths
and microservices
that I have heard.
So Travis, what were some
of the main challenges
that you all were
going through while you
had this monolith turducken
setting of the architecture?
I'm pretty sure
there were challenges
that made you think that
moving to microservices
was a good choice.
What were some of
those challenges?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well, we had
monitoring and debugging
challenges.
So each customer essentially
ended up in their own instance.
And so trying to
track down issues
and trying to tell what the
health of the applications
were was really
difficult. We also found
that it was taking
days, if not weeks,
to get new customers onboarded,
which certainly isn't scalable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I'm
actually curious about how
the infrastructure was initially
when it was a monolith.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
So originally, we had CDs that
we would send out to customers.
We were, you know, it was
an on-premise application.
So we just had to take that
and just put it into the cloud,
naturally.
And unfortunately,
what this meant
is that we ballooned into
5,000 different VMs, which,
as I mentioned, isn't scalable.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So as you start to have 5,000
VMs, that definitely is a lot.
I'm assuming you
started to think
you needed to move to Cloud.
What was that
thought process like?
TRAVIS DEPUY: We rented
space in six different data
centers across the world.
So we thought about,
why are we getting
into dealing with hardware.
You know?
Google does that
very, very well.
So why don't we leave
it to the experts?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
What were some
of the architectural
components at a high level
that you were
looking at as a part
of microservices architecture?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
So naturally, the
application was composed
of several different pieces.
So we had the web
user interface,
we had API interfaces,
and we also
have notification services,
so being able to reach out
to email, or SMS, or
voice calls were all
their own kind of service.
Then there was also
the on-call scheduling,
so trying to figure out
who's currently on call.
And so these were kind
of the early things
we were able to identify that we
could pull apart and tease out
of the application to make
them their own service.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
When you all were
starting to move
to microservices,
what was the end goal in mind?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Primarily scale.
Maintaining 5,000 VMs
is just not scalable.
So we tried to identify
different aspects
that we could pull out
some of the redundancy.
So, for example, we have
this application gateway
that's speeding traffic
into the different services.
So we're able to identify
different places that we can
start to move to microservices.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And then so how
did that start to
look in Google Cloud
from the architectural
perspective?
What are the components
you were using?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
So we had a web user interface.
We had application APIs.
We had notification services
and on-call scheduling.
So all these were
different microservices
that we were able to
pull out and break off
into their own microservice.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
application gateway approach
really sounds interesting
and the natural thing
to do when you're starting out
with microservices, breaking up
your monolith.
What are the components that you
ended up using on Google Cloud?
What did the
architecture look like?
TRAVIS DEPUY: So we used Google
with DNS for IP address lookup.
And then users are routed
through the global load
balancer, which gets them
into the application gateway.
So from there, the user devices,
such as web and mobile devices,
are routed into the various
microservices that are all
running on GKE, using images
stored in Google Container
Registry.
The data backend is running
on Google Compute Engine.
Then we have the
monitoring running, also
using Prometheus, Splunk,
and, of course, Stackdriver.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now, when you
decided to actually get the GKE
services on, what were
some of the services
that you picked out or
selected from the monolith that
were going to go on.
What was the decision
making process around that,
and what were some
of those services?
TRAVIS DEPUY: So
the application is
composed of many
different pieces,
so it made logical sense to pull
those different pieces apart
into their own services.
So, for example, we have
the web user interface.
It provides the web interface
for the various users.
Then we have the API
interfaces, as well as, I
like on-call scheduling.
So it's its own service to
figure out, OK, who's currently
on call when an event comes in.
And then there's
the data services.
You know, keeping track of
users and their devices,
and things like that.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So that
brings up a very interesting
and a very important point when
it comes to migrating monoliths
to microservices, because
data dependencies are key.
And every service has
some sort of dependency
on another service.
So this question
always comes up,
as to how do you actually
define which services should
be migrated first,
or how do you deal
with those data dependencies?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yes, certainly.
Microservices, you
know, are very rarely
just standalone services.
You know, they always
depend on other pieces.
So we just really made sure to
release the services in cadence
with each other as we started
to build out the application.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
so mainly just making sure
that you list out
those services that you
may want to move
to microservices,
and then you define
the dependencies,
and then depending on which
one's dependent on each other,
or less dependent
on each other, you
define which one goes
first versus next.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yep.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, well
that makes a lot of sense.
So we have a bunch of
chopped veggies here.
What do we do next?
TRAVIS DEPUY: We're going
to throw them in the pan
and then we'll add in the broth.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, awesome.
Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This definitely seems like a
pretty difficult and daunting
task.
How long did it actually take to
finish out the entire migration
process?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well, once
we made the decision
to commit to Cloud, it
took us about 12 months,
because we had data
center contracts that
were coming up for renewal.
So it was either get our stuff
out or buy more data center.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
Yeah, well, those
are obviously very
good situations to kind of push
you towards a good timeline.
Was there a time when you
were running in GCP as well as
in your on-premise environment?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
We were running them both
for about six months.
The flexibility of the
Google Cloud Platform
allowed us to do that.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, it always
seems that it's
important to understand
that the beauty of
migration is, you're
not going to just move
stuff from here to here.
It's always going to be
a gradual process where
you move some services over, and
you have both platforms running
for at least a
considerable amount of time
so you can go back and
forth between platforms.
It seems like that's what
xMatters ended up doing.
You had six months in Google
Cloud, and also running
parallelly on premises in order
to facilitate the migration.
Can you talk a little bit about
the challenges, or rather,
the success metrics that
actually led to that migration?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah.
So metrics are critical.
You know, we started with
monitoring and observability
right off the bat
so that we knew
that, as we introduced changes
to the entire environment,
we could see how they
impacted the different aspects
of the system.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
Stackdriver, I'm pretty sure,
played a really big role
in that monitoring journey.
But I'm pretty curious about
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and how did that play a role
in those incremental changes
as you were gradually
moving over to Cloud.
TRAVIS DEPUY: So
GKE is definitely
the central part of our
microservices architecture.
We also use GKE VPC native
IPs for direct addressing.
And then we also use
a sidecar pattern
for incremental deployments.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So Travis, what
is the most challenging
part of actually moving
into microservices pattern?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Sorting out
the service ownership.
So mapping the teams,
the different services,
as well as deploying those
services into the environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We
did touch a little bit
on how to find out
the services that
needed to be migrated,
and then prioritize them
in the sequence, and
all of those things.
That is really hard to do.
Should we check on our soup?
Because I think--
TRAVIS DEPUY: I think it
smells like it's getting there.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah, OK.
So let's do that.
So Travis, this
change must have been
really new for the development
and the operations team,
because they are
learning something new.
Moving into
microservices, they're
designing things differently.
They're working on
them differently.
The cadence might be different.
How did you go about making
the development and operations
team feel comfortable
about the change?
TRAVIS DEPUY: You
know, Jez Humble
talks about this really well.
He says that bad behavior
arises when you abstract teams
from the consequences
of their actions.
So we really tried to align
the teams with the services
that they had to
build and maintain.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So basically, they
will be accountable for
the SLOs if you give them
more ownership and more
accountability for the work
that they are doing.
So now that you've gone
through this migration,
what are the impacts that
you're starting to see?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well, happier
customers mean happier teams.
Empirically, we found that
we had a 43% performance
improvement as well
as 60% less incidents.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
happy team and happy customers
definitely sounds
like a win to me.
Apart from this, as you are
now already into a Google Cloud
with the microservices,
broken down from a monolith,
what are you seeing
as the next steps?
Where do we want to go from
the architectural perspective?
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well, total
domination of the market,
of course.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, apart from that.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Well
architecturally, we'll
look into moving into
service mesh architecture,
so you're probably using Istio.
And that will allow us to get
rid of this application gateway
and it'll let the microservices
talk to each other directly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
Service mesh definitely seems
like the next logical step
to take where you can connect,
secure, control, and observe
your applications while in
a microservices fashion.
Well, awesome.
That was very
insightful, Travis.
Thank you so much
for having me over.
TRAVIS DEPUY: Yeah,
thanks for coming.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thanks
for joining us today.
I'm glad you were able to
catch the recipe of migrating
a monolith to microservices
with xMatters.
If you liked this
video, then stay
tuned for more such episodes
of Get Cooking in Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]